Schön. Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Dr. Yücel. Ich bin der Dienshabende Arzt in der Not-Aufnahme.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschichte führen.
Was ist dein Verständnis?
Ja klar, hapt euch jemanden kuppen kann.
Ja.
Ich würde ganz kurz eine Person frage stellen, dann werde ich ihre aktuelle Bescheide kommen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Rainer Hager.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vornahme und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, mein Vorname R-A-I-N-E-R.
Und der Nachname Ha-A-G-E-R.
Haager. Und ich bin ein Mann.
Okay. Herr Haager.
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Haager?
Ich bin 49, nächstes Jahr werde ich 50.
Gut. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 19. April 1973.
Herr Haager, wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
Ja, ich bin 1,80 m und ich wiege so 91 kg meistens so.
Okay. Herr Haager, was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe so unglaublich starke Rückenschmerzen.
Und zwar eigentlich so im unteren Rücken.
Das strahlt bis ins rechte Bein rein.
Das geht an der Außenseite vom Bein runter, zieht das bis zu den 10.
Das wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Die ganze rechte Gesäßhälfte tut mir weh.
Ich konnte mich kaum rühren.
Ich konnte heute Nacht fast nicht schlafen.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie ich mich hinlegen sollte.
Und wenn ich die Position verändern wollte,
das war extrem schmerzhaft.
Oder auch aufstehen heute Morgen.
Oder auf die Toilette gehen.
Das tut alles weh.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leichter und 10 stärkster Schmerzen entschieblich sind?
Ich denke, bei 7, 8 ist das schon.
Das schießt in dem Augenblick, wo ich mich auch nur ein bisschen bewege.
Das schießt ordentlich rein.
Okay.
Können Sie dich mal genau beschreiben, wie sind die Schmerzen,
durkend oder stetschend?
Das ist ein heißes Brändestechen.
Haben Sie Taubheit gefühlt oder kribben?
Ja, die kleine Zehkribbel so ein bisschen.
Das ist ein sehr heißes Brändestechen.
Die kleine Zehkribbel so ein bisschen.
An rechten Beinen außen fühlt sich das ein bisschen taub an.
Haben Sie muskul-schwechungen bemerkt?
Hast du mich bemerkt?
Muskul-lermung oder schwechungen?
Ich habe nur das Gefühl, dass das Taub ist.
Ich könnte darauf aufreden, aber es ist so schmerzhaft,
dass ich das Bein schone.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen erst einmal aufgetreten oder hatten Sie schon mal diese Schmerzen gehabt?
Ich habe schon seit Monaten immer, wenn ich mal ein bisschen mehr körperlich mich belastet habe,
habe ich immer mal Rötenschmerzen.
Aber gestern habe ich bei mir auf der Terrasse und im Garten ein bisschen aufgeräumt.
Da habe ich einen schweren Blumentopf weggehoben.
Da ist es mir so reingeschossen.
Das war wohl der Auslöser.
Normalerweise ist es immer wieder weggegangen, wenn ich mich ein bisschen wieder geschont habe.
Aber jetzt schießen mir die Tränen in die Augen, wenn ich mich nur ein bisschen bewege.
Das sind wirklich starke Schmerzen.
Ich verstehe sehr.
Können Sie enden das Geschenk, die sich verschen, auszuhalten?
Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht viel bewege, geht es ja.
Wenn ich hier still sitzen kann, aber sobald ich irgendwie aufstehen muss, wird es schon wieder sehr schmerzhaft.
Ja, das ist ein riesiger Kübel, der auf der Terrasse stand.
Den habe ich halt versucht zur Seite zu heben.
Da habe ich dann gemerkt, das war zu viel.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasalas?
Können Sie Wasalas in der Hand halten?
Ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasalas?
Ich habe keine Schwierigkeiten.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe nur eine Unverträglichkeit, wenn ich Rohlebensmittel esse.
Rohes Gemüse oder Rohes Obst, dann kriege ich leicht Blähungen.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme mit der Verdauung.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie auf Haselospollen.
Wenn die Haselus in Frühblühen, dann kriege ich heute so tränende Augen
und verstopfte Nase.
Dann hat man festgestellt, dass ich auf Amoxicillin allergisch reagiere.
Da habe ich einen Hautausschlag bekommen.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Ein Unfall?
Ja, vor ein, zwei Tagen.
Nein, ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt.
Ich habe im Garten gearbeitet.
Das habe ich ja gesagt.
Haben Sie Fieber oder hatten Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe zwar nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht fieberig.
Auch Schwinderik?
Nein, ich habe Rückenschmerzen.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Nein, ich habe definitiv nicht gut geschlafen.
Ich habe es beim Liegen und Bewegung.
Normalerweise habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Aber heute Nacht war es wirklich schlecht.
Haben Sie in Leicester seit ungewollt gewischt Abgenomen oder Sugenomen?
Nein, nein.
Herr Haier, ist Ihnen Corona-Erkrankungen bekannt wie Bluthochdruck, Diabetes, Blut-Sucke?
Als Kind bin ich schon Diabetiker.
Ich habe eine Insulinpumpe und bin damit eigentlich ganz gut eingestellt.
Ich habe ja irgendwann einen hohen Blutdruck und die Blutfettwerte sind seit ein paar Jahren erhöht.
Ich nehme aber Medikamente.
Ich nehme Atobastatin wegen der Blutfettwerte.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Oh, was steht da drauf? Ich meine 10, dann nehme ich eine am Abend.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch anderen Vorerkrankungen?
Vor anderthalb Jahren hatte ich mein Hörsturz und da habe ich jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen Ohrgeräusche.
Das ist ein bisschen störend.
Ich nehme eine Medikamente wegen des Tebulitis.
Ich nehme Tebulin 120.
120.
Einmal täglich.
Ja, und wegen des Blutdrucks nehme ich Mikades Plus.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Das ist 40 zu 12,5.
40 zu 12,5.
Da ist noch irgend eine andere Becher.
Ja, richtig.
Und haben Sie noch anderen chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, lang ja auch mehr als genug.
Okay.
Ist leiden Sie an Tipp 1, Diabetes mellitus?
Ja, ich habe noch einen anderen Becher.
Wie viele Einheiten müssen Sie auf meiner Liste angucken?
Die Insulinpumpe stellt sich automatisch ein.
Automatisch, ja.
Okay.
Herr Hage, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ne, operiert worden bin ich noch nicht. Nein.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne einige Fragen über Ihre Familie stellen.
Sind Ihr Eltern an Leben?
Meine Eltern leben noch beide, ja.
Ist bei Ihnen einige Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Ich weiß nur, dass mein Vater Hüftprobleme hat.
Er hat eine Erkrankung,
da steht im Raum, dass der irgendwann mal ein künstliches Gelenk bekommt.
Meine Mutter hat irgendwie Augenprobleme,
da so Makula-Veränderungen.
Da ist sie aber auch in Behandlung.
Haben Sie noch anderen, die Sie nicht mehr haben,
haben Sie auch noch eine Erkrankung?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Erkrankung.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Wahrscheinlich haben die auch ein bisschen hohen Druck,
das jeder ungefähr hat.
Ja, ganz schön.
Haben Sie geschwistert, Herr Hage?
Geschwister habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Zöne.
Sind beide gesündert?
Die beiden, die haben ich nicht gekauft.
Das ist schon gelungen.
Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie eine Familie zusammen?
Wir haben alle zusammen, ja.
Okay, Herr Hage,
haben Sie eine Rauchen?
Rauchen kann man das fast nicht nennen.
Eigentlich ist das nur so,
dass ich bei der Arbeit nach dem Essen mit den Kollegen
eine Zigarette rauchen und dann auch noch Feierabend eine.
Das sind nur so zwei, drei Zigaretten am Tag,
aber das mache ich schon ewig lange, ja.
Seit wann brauchen Sie?
Ach, das ist schon so 15 Jahre oder so.
Hab ich irgendwie mit dem Job angefangen,
damit ich mit den Kollegen zusammen vor die Tür gehen kann.
Okay.
Herr Hage, trinken Sie Regalmusik, Alkohol?
Björn Glas Wein am Tag trinke ich wohl.
Und hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
War schon mächtig lange her,
aber ich habe natürlich in meiner Jugend mal Haschisch probiert.
Aber das war relativ wenig, dass ich das mal ausprobiert habe.
Okay, Herr Hage, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Ihnen ja viel erzählt.
Für mich ist jetzt nur wichtig, was kann man gegen diese Schmerzen machen.
Und woher kann das kommen, dass das so hält?
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen,
aber ich habe noch ein paar Fragen,
aber woher kann das kommen, dass das so heftige Schmerzen sind,
Ja, von alleine nicht weg, oder?
Ja, mit Medikamente kann das manchmal weg.
Aber so als sollten wir einige weitere Untersuchungen durschieren.
Vielleicht ist das ja etwas anderes, das wäre ja gut, ja.
Wir müssen ihre Bandcheiben durschieren, MRT oder CT, ZEHN kuchen
und danach eine Diagnose feststellen.
Ja, das erklären Sie mir dann, was CT und MRT ist, ne?
Ja, ich würde gerne erklären. CT und MRT, wie gleiche Untersuchungsmethode,
die sind moderne Untersuchungsmethode und mit Hilfe dieses Untersuchung können wir die Be von Körper und Organen gut sehen.
Das ist eine...
Bei Maren kann man ja nur die Knochen, ne?
Ja, mit Röntgen können wir nur knacken sehen, aber mit Magnetresonansomorifi können wir alle Nerven, alle Gewäbe und Organen und auch Gehin können wir gut beurteilen.
Ah, ja.
Aber wir gucken hier nach dem Kopf, ne?
Ja, natürlich. Wir gucken rücken. Bei dieser Untersuchung müssen Sie sich auf eine Lige legen, die langsam in das MRT gerät hineinfangen.
Das ist man in so einer Röhre drin, ne?
Ja, eine Röhre.
Mhm.
Während in dieser Untersuchung sehr wichtig sie sollten beruhigen und ohne bewegen, bei MRT und Untersuchung treten auch starke Geräusche auf.
Daher geben wir ihnen auch einen Gehör.
Angehör?
Oh, jetzt steht mein Bild.
Bin ich ausgestiegen oder bin ich ausgestiegen?
Wir hören nämlich die anderen.
Hörschutz, richtig?
Ich kriege ein Gehörschutz, richtig?
Ja, ich... wir geben ihnen einen Gehörschutz.
Diese Untersuchung dauert 20 oder 30 Minuten. MRT ist eine ohnechralende Untersuchung.
Ah, das ist ja interessant. Ja.
Und können wir das jetzt dann gleich machen?
Oder muss man da erst ein paar Tage wahren?
Ja, ich muss mit unseren Kollegen sprechen.
Wahrscheinlich können wir Notfall ein MRT durchführen.
Ah ja, das wäre ja gut.
Okay, gut, dann habe ich keine Weitbandfragen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Hab ich einen Kollegen oder Kollegen, Ragen.
Ich denke in Status und in Seibensport, die sind, fehlt noch, oder?
Was fehlt?
In Status, infungen.
Ach, infund, ja. Ja, gut, okay.
Und Sport, Seibensport.
Ach so, ja, natürlich.
Macht ja keinen Sport.
Doch, der macht ja ein bisschen was im Garten, ne?
Der arbeitet ein bisschen was im Garten und hin und wieder fährt er mal Fahrrad.
Und natürlich ist er gegen Corona geämpft, ja.
Wie viel Zeit sind Sie da und Sie irgendwie mit der Kamera eingenommen?
Nein, er hat keine eingenommen, weil er gehofft hat, dass er schnell wieder weggeht.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Ingenieur.
Was für Ingenieur?
Maschinenbaum.
Ich habe die Probleme beim Ehe bei Süßes zu abhinden.
Nee, er hat ja nicht, er hat nur Schmerzen.
Und es kribbelt in den Fuß, also in den Zehen.
Und er belastet nicht, weil er Schmerzen hat.
Wenn Sie anfangen damit.
Also, noch eine, Sie haben schon gestört, das Allergie.
Allergie hat er gefragt.
Aber man muss, ich denke, kann man auch wiederholen, haben Sie eine Kontrastmieterallergie?
Weil Sie.
Ach ja, ja, stimmt.
Er hat nur Amoxizidsthylidin und Haselnusspeulen als Allergien angegeben.
Und Kontrastmieterallergie ist nicht bekannt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob man da nochmal irgendwie vorher etwas testen muss.
Gut, können wir los?
Oder nicht?
Eine Kollegin, sind Sie stressausgesetzt im Arbeit oder im Haus?
Eigentlich nicht.
Dankeschön, da ist es.
Bitte schön, Möbeth.
Hallo, guten Abend Frau Oberarsten.
Guten Abend.
Wenn Sie Seite haben, würde ich gerne Ihnen unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, gerne, Nummer 2.
Herr Rainer Hage ist ein 49-Jähriger Patient, der sich bei uns wegen
der
Wir haben eine Szenen, die wir in der Szenen haben, mit dem Zibbeln, bis auf die Schmerzskala gewertet.
Aus einem Berichtete, der das Dichmersen stechend und brennend sei,
darüber hinaus klagte er über Parästhesi in erster Szene.
Er hat gesagt, der kleinen See hat eine Hypoesthesi in der
Rechte bein. Seit Monatem habe er bei Belastung enden sich Beschwerden gehabt.
Gestern seien die Schmerzen nach einer Bulumentopfaufsugehoben aufgetreten.
Er hat eine Hazelnusspolenallergie bekannt, die sich durch Nasokonjuaktivitis
und eine Amoxicillinallergie bekannt, die mit Exantem äußert.
Er hat eine Hypoesthesi in der Rechte beendet.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Ich beachte die Muskulkraft und Sensibilität, auch Szenenreflexe und auch Sensibilität
und Kraftlösigkeit.
Was gucken Sie noch?
Ich bin wieder da.
Was machen Sie noch?
Warum wollen Sie röntgen?
Was würden Sie für Laboruntersuchungen anstreben?
Was wäre die Therapie?
Was wäre der Maximale Behandlung?
Der Patient sollte immer bei Belastung beachten.
Was ist die letzte Option?
Die letzte Option ist die operative Behandlung.
Welcher Nerven ist betroffen?
Ich bin gespannt, was bei MRT rauskommt.
Ich hoffe, dass wir den Patienten helfen können.
Das war alles da.
Ich habe noch ein paar Sachen, die ich intervenieren möchte.
Als echter Patient würde ich zusammenzucken.
Sie möchten ja keine persönlichen Fragen stellen, sondern zur Person stellen.
Wenn man mich nach meinem Namen und Geburtstag fragt, dann ist das die Frage nach meinen persönlichen Daten.
Das ist ein kleiner Unterschied.
Der Vater hatte noch keine Hüft-Tab.
Er hat Probleme mit der Hüfte.
Die Schmerzen strahlen bis zu den Zähnen.
Die Zähne sind die Zähnen.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, wie sie den Hergang schildert haben.
Das ist eine Schwachstelle bei vielen Gesprächen.
Die Schmerzen sind nach einem Blumentopfheben aufgetreten.
Das ist nicht ganz verkehrt.
Er war draußen im Garten kalt und hat eine ungewöhnliche Bewegung gemacht.
Das müsste man anders beschreiben.
Der Patient schilderte, dass er bei der Arbeiten einen sehr schweren Blumenkübel verschoben hat.
Danach sind die Schmerzen eingeschossen.
Ich habe einen ganzen Satz draus gemacht.
Der Klassiker hat einen Unterschied zwischen einem punktuellen Ereignis und einer andauernden Erkrankung.
Der Patient hatte vor 1,5 Jahren einen Hörsturz.
An einem Zeitpunkt hatte er den Hörsturz.
Er ist geblieben.
Seit diesem Ereignis hat er den Tinnitus.
Er hat eine kleine Würde, um den Unterschied zu machen.
Mehr habe ich nicht zum Maul.
Er hat eine kleine Würde, um zu machen.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen üben, sofort laufend ein Text zu sprechen.
Das ist eine ordinaire Methode.
Dann kriegen Sie Fluss in Ihre Sprache.